can't believe that's actually
outperforming my 12
core mac pro we finally got our new 10
core imac in with the high-end 5700x
graphics
seems like it's been forever of a weight
and today we're gonna see
how this thing performs now let me be
honest i know this thing is going to be
super powerful
looking at the 8 core that thing is
already excellent but what i'm curious
about is how loud
will this thing be and how hot will it
run with 10
cores inside this machine so we're going
to figure out all of that we're going to
figure out
how much wattage it pulls we're going to
see how it performs and i'm even going
to compare it
to my mac pro before we jump in i have
to mention two things first off this
modern apple products shirt from max
tech
super comfortable make sure you go pick
one up in the merch shelf or grab one of
those masks that are really popular
right now and number two
we saved a ton of money installing ram
ourselves it took less than a minute
we have 64 gigabytes here it's working
perfectly how much does apple charge
a thousand dollars a thousand dollars
apple charges for 64 gigs and we paid
250 so we saved 750
in a matter of less than a minute really
make sure you follow our ram install
guide we'll have a link down below and
save yourself a bunch of money
let's jump right into geekbench 5 and
one interesting thing that i noticed
is this is labeled an i9 10 910 cpu i
was expecting the 10 900k
but it looks like it's a modified
version we'll see how it performs
uh let's hit run cpu benchmark and i
have intel power gadget open i want to
see the frequencies we hit
and how much wattage apple is allowing
the imac to run at so it looks like the
10 core the max it will hit is 5.0
just as advertised but it's good to see
that we're actually hitting that
where a lot of times on the macbook pros
they get close but they don't
and now we have 150 657
watts here 159
once we got some of the tougher tests
that is really high
the previous i9 from last year the
highest it
is 115 in geekbench 5. so
apple is allowing this epu to get as
much power
as it needs to have great performance
now for reference the a core the base
one that comes this year
that hit 129 this year and actually went
up to one
5.1 gigahertz for some reason slightly
higher than it's actually rated alright
we have our score
and i have to say this is interesting
our multi-core score is 97.37 which
is higher than even the 10 core imac pro
but if we do the math that is just about
ten percent more performance
than the a core that comes included
without having to do this upgrade that
costs four hundred dollars more
and ten cores it's about 25 more core so
we're not getting
you know a linear amount of performance
and then compared to last year's i9 it's
about 17 percent
more powerful this i9 compared to 2019
and now let's talk about the single core
1271 that's the highest single core
score out of any
mac and what's interesting is not only
does it beat out the 10 core imac pro
which i expected
but last year's i9 that was actually the
fastest
this year's i7 beat it and then this i9
beats it once again
so not only do we have 10 cores now in
the system
but it doesn't give up any single core
performance to
the lower core models and now let's
touch on the graphics i'm going to go
ahead and run
the metal test and what really excites
me about this new imac is apple put
in the 5700 xt graphics card inside of
here
that's the graphics card that i
recommend most people get if they do
video editing on the mac pro
it's the graphics card we recommend for
egpu setups
and not only do they pop the desktop
class card in here
but they also double the video memory so
if you just buy that graphics card for
your pc or your
gpu is eight gigs of memory this one has
16
just like the one that you can get on
the mac pro but it costs less money to
upgrade to
and we have our score and wow that is
disappointing
57 898
we were expecting about 70 75
000 that's roughly what they get in a
mac pro
with the egpu you're looking more at
about this performance
i want to go ahead and run that again
because it seems like it should be doing
better than that i don't know if apple
maybe
down clocked the ones in this imac
just so that it doesn't put out as much
heat or something like that
and with our second round we got 59 417
almost 60 000 now with that said with
the 5500 xt that we have in our acore
model
it scored fairly low in metal but in the
real world
video editing and other tests that we
ran it actually performed
really really well so we'll have to do
some more testing
now let's go ahead and open up unigine
heaven which is a gaming benchmark
and we'll see if we notice a bigger
difference here now as this is running i
want to point something out that just
popped into my mind
so far things are kind of opposite from
what i expected i expected the
performance scores to be higher
but i also expected the fan noise to be
much
louder and so far it's been completely
silent
we'll see what we get towards the end of
this run but right now the graphics is
running at just 75 degrees celsius
the test is done and wow we have
96.2 frames per second which is 50
percent faster
than the 5500 xt that we have in our 8
core model
and about 45 faster than the best
graphics card that you could get
last year which was the vega 48 not only
that
it also beats out the vega 56 and the
vegas 64 in the imac pro
and looking at this score it's better
than i expected whereas the metal test
in geekbench 5 was lower than i expected
so there might be something with drivers
or the testing that's going on
because the real world tests that we're
seeing with these new graphics cards in
2020s
are really good and with that i want to
talk about thermals right now we're
running at about 87 degrees celsius
and the fans did spin up just a little
bit above
idle so if you are quiet
you can slightly hear it almost like a
whisper but it is still
running quiet even after i think it's
been more than two runs it keeps cycling
here in the background so that is a
great thing
and now for the ultimate test we have
cinebench r20 here we're gonna max out
all 10 of these cores while keeping an
eye on
our temperatures our noise the wattage
let's go ahead and get started here
right away
our wattage is going up here 80 watts
142 146
148 it's leveling off which is
interesting 150.
last year's i9 only hit 120 but
interestingly the 2028
core actually hit 161
in this test now we're getting these
little wattage spikes and these little
temperature spikes
which is showing me that it's actually
throttling down the wattage
in order to keep it from getting too hot
and the fans only now
are starting to spin up before it was
silent so only towards the end of the
test
and we have a score of 5 398 basically
5400
for our first run i'm gonna run that
again we're gonna see
what our actual temperature stabilizes
that in the clock speed stable
stabilize that but 5400 is right around
where my 12
core mac pro actually gets
instead of bench r20 even though we have
two less cores
we're finishing up with our third
consecutive run right now the fans are
at full blast
2700 rpms and it looks like the
stabilized clock speed is right at 4
to 4.03 4.06
last year's i9 actually did 3.75
gigahertz was what it stabilized that so
this year even with more cores
uh the same cooling it's actually
running better
but it's not running at that 4.4
gigahertz that the a core runs at
i just let it cool down for a little bit
and i ran it one more time we got to
score a 55
35 which is higher than my
mac pro and i wanted to see this time
just that curve of how
long it takes for it to heat up because
it does run hot
and it is a much smoother curve it only
heats up towards the end of the test
compared to some of the other macs which
they heat up instantly
part part of that is because apple's
limiting this at 150 watts with the a
core
it actually can go higher than this 10
core so they're trying to keep this
thing cool
but in general you could expect 5400 to
5535 as far as performance now this
score is
38 higher and faster than the previous
last year's i9
but with that said it's about 14 faster
than this year's
eight core which you do have to spend
another 400 dollars to get that extra 14
of performance now in geekbench 5 we saw
that it was more like a 10 percent
performance and that's with about 25
more cores just because that can run at
a higher wattage
and higher clock speeds but that doesn't
tell the whole story we also have a
bunch of other videos planned we're
going to do a bootcamp gaming video
i'm going to compare how this does to my
15 000
mac pro and a lot more so make sure you
guys are subscribed you guys have those
notifications enabled so you don't miss
that so overall
what did we learn well first off the
graphics card that is in here is
super fast at least in the one real
world test that we did
it by far outperforms having an egpu
with the same graphics chip
we also learned that the 10 core isn't
that much faster than the 8 core that
you can get
with while saving a lot of money and
based on our real world tests
you might want to just skip that option
i also learned that it's not as loud as
i
expected apple's doing a good job
managing the thermals so it doesn't heat
up that fast the fans don't ramp up
super fast
and for the gaming test it actually
stayed surprisingly
quiet so there we have it guys let us
know any questions that you have down in
the comment section below if you're
interested or if you have a video idea
let us know make sure to check out our
merch this
this shirt is super comfortable make
sure you get the premium one like i have
here
this has been max and we'll see you in
the next video